teame
今から質問コーナーを行います
自己紹介をしてください8同源と言います生まれは14世紀の日本です
同件を13世紀だろうとここで突っ込みたくなる人は多いかと思いますが僕はのそう
東京の有名な道元禅師ではありません彼の
べし
のでし
の多いですどうやら父は禅師の名前が好きなようでした道元には直接会ったことは残念
ながらありませんがおじさんに憧れて自分も20年以上毎日左前を組みましたが
ようやく悟りを開いた次の日に腐った枝豆に命を奪われました
そして600年間煉獄でぼーっとして
いたらある日突然このひょろっとした白人の体に生まれ変わり
ん
ケビンというとても平凡の名前を付けられました
いやありがとう
とーちゃんかー煉獄での600年間をもちろん孤独だったので欧米の社会に生まれた時
は日本語がやはり離せなくなっていました
c 日本語自体が別物に変わっていましたそれで若い頃カセットテープというものを
買って新日本語を独学しました
また大学時代にも自分以外のひょろーとした白人男性
数十人と日本語を勉強してました彼らも生まれ変わった坊主なのかそれとも単なる
オタクなのか今でも不明です
面白いことに道元禅師のことを勉強してる人も大学に言いました
彼らも生まれ変わった坊主なのかそれとも単なるオタクなのか今でも不明です神の長い
綺麗な日本人女性もその講座を受けていて
僕いつも彼女をカフェの向こうはゴミを出しちゃった
大学卒業後はすぐに日本に戻りまし自分の過去の話は誰も信じてくれないということは
重々分かっていたので
永平寺に戻る代わりに僕は日本の子どもたちにアメリカの汚れた資本主義社会で身に
付けた英語数年間教えることにしました
その間に近くに住んでいる外国人の英語の教師に悟りの秘訣を教え
その上650年も前から放っそうに抱えていた秘密の趣味にも予約取り組み始め
とそう僕は喜劇を書き始めた
木間何さ28歳血液型は a です戦闘力はいくつ
逆8000
か要件を使えば16000好きなサッカーをさんにあげると金原ひとみ
村上龍三島由紀夫恋人とはどこで知り合った不思議な縁を見たら1週間後テレビから出
てきた
動物に例えるとファイナルファンタジー7のエメラルドウェットスターバックスの好き
な vip
今日何時に起きた7時半1億円あったら何に使う
ショパンにテーマソングを作ってもらう好きな場所
横浜のみなとみらい外国で一番行きたいところ
今一番行きたいのは撮るウェイインスターグラムの好きな
もっとも気に入れの日本のアルバム
絶対に椎名林檎無罪モラトリアムいや
宇多田ヒカルのディープレザーやスーパーカードファイルでしょ
最終形パリ椎名林檎の勝訴や午後なにちわーシャチのだそこや
やっちー何口が東京地やソフトボールの会無理だよ個室
もっともお気に入りの日本の歌
ああああああああああああ